blast light is the world's smallest
and most convenient uvc disinfection
light to help keep you safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com light to get it
for
forty percent off the link is down below
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman i
want to start today by talking about
a new statement from the cdc about
coronavirus vaccination
of younger people and what appears to be
a link to a very rare
uh heart condition which can also be
caused by the virus itself
and i think i feel driven to
kind of preface this by saying on the
one hand i've been a huge
advocate of vaccination and continue to
be and this doesn't change that
and so for people who will react to me
talking about this by saying are you
going anti-vaccine
absolutely not uh the risks of this
condition with the vaccine are far lower
than the risks of the very same
condition if you get covid
uh on the other hand for people who have
been saying david you won't ever
talk about the side effects of vaccines
well you're also wrong because i'm
talking about them
right here so let's get right into it
cdc safety group says there's a likely
link
between rare heart inflammation in young
people
after covid shot there have been more
than 1200 cases
of a myocarditis or pericarditis mostly
in
30 and under people who received
pfizer's
or modernist covid19 vaccine according
to cdc data
roughly 300 million shots had been
administered as of june 11th
for both vaccines combined there were 12
heart inflammation cases per million
doses the cdc safety group is calling it
a likely association between this rare
heart inflammatory condition in
adolescents and young adults
mostly after they've received their
second shot
based on the most recent data available
1200
cases according to a series of
presentations published yesterday
wednesday
myocarditis is the inflammation of the
heart muscle
pericarditis is the inflammation of the
membrane surrounding the heart
dr grace lee chairs the cdc safety group
says
clinical presentation of myocarditis
cases following vaccination
has been distinct occurring most often
within one week after dose two
with chest pain as the most common
presentation um
information is being gathered about how
to manage
this the agency said there have been 267
cases of myocarditis or pericarditis
after one dose
and 827 after two doses
132 additional cases where doses
received
is unknown importantly dr
tom shimabakuro says this is still a
rare event
it's mostly men under 30. remember the
blood clotting with the j
and j was mostly women under 45
this is mostly men under 30. very
important of the 295 people who
developed the condition and have been
discharged
79 percent fully recovered nine were
hospitalized
two in intensive care so there's no
reason to hide this we want to
understand the risks
and uh understand any medication
treatment or whatever that that we are
obtaining
um when you look at these numbers you're
talking about
out of 300 million doses two people in
intensive care
and so we should be aware of this as
vaccination sites uh are told about this
and
develop protocol for managing it this is
why you
um have all of this data and do this
research
the vaccine is still way safer at all
ages than getting coveted that's an
important thing to remember
we now know i know personally of people
of a variety of ages 25 plus
dying of covid i know of one person
with an allergic reaction to the vaccine
that was sort of serious
she was brought to the er and was fine
after a couple of hours there's no
reason to hide this stuff
it looks bad to hide it it should be
reported in proper context and remember
that
covet itself comes with risk of heart
inflammation and it's a really important
thing
uh to remember so information is still
being gathered about this
it's extraordinarily rare and
even in almost all cases where this rare
thing happens
people make a full recovery those are
the facts as we understand them
right now and as more information comes
forward about this of course
i will present it to you earlier this
week i talked to you about how
republican
governor of florida ron desantis is in
some sense out
trumping trump and what i mean by that
is that desantis is like trump in that
he has this
um authoritarian kind of unhinged
tendency he's primarily concerned with
virtue signaling and self-aggrandizement
but he's different than donald trump in
that ron desantis is more competent
and this makes him more dangerous
particularly as he's being thought of
as a possible future republican
presidential candidate and ron desantis
is now
signing a series of bills but in
particular i want to talk about one bill
today
that will require it will require that
high school students be taught about the
quote
evils of communism the bill will also
create a library
that will allow students to learn about
quote real patriots
who escaped communism and socialism
it's that insane let's take a listen uh
to what ron desantis had to say
yesterday and this is
really really weaponized stuff
curriculum can really provide
a guide to how that should be done the
bill also expands
our previous efforts in civics to add a
requirement for the high school
government class
that students receive instruction on the
evils of communism
and totalitarian ideologies now
if you want to make the case that as a
matter of economics classes
students should learn about marxism
alongside
keynesianism keynesianism and
neoclassical economics
i'm all for it i took marxian economics
as an undergraduate student uh my uh uh
you know my experience was was fantastic
i got to learn about it it didn't
convert me into a marxist but it was
extremely useful
if you want to argue that communism as a
system of government should be taught
in history class in political science
government whatever it's called
within the florida high school level uh
i think that that's a fantastic thing
that's different than mandating
propaganda
about communism to be taught let's
listen to a little more
we have a number of people in in florida
particularly southern florida
who've escaped totalitarian regimes
who've escaped communist dictatorships
to be able to come to america uh we want
all students to understand
the difference why would somebody flee
across
shark infested water say leaving from
cuba to come to southern florida
why would somebody leave a place like
vietnam
why would people leave these countries
and risk their life to be able to come
here
it's important that students understand
that now as part of this bill
florida will create a portraits and
patriotism library
so students can learn about real
patriots who came to this country
right after seeing the horrors of these
communist regimes
we actually have uh folks here today
you'll hear from her in a minute anna
abauza
she came to the united states when she
was a teenager fleeing from
nicaragua when the sandinistas brought
socialism to that country
she graduated from the university of
florida okay
so uh i think that
high school students should be taught
about the history of the soviet union
cuba nicaragua vietnam in a historically
accurate way
properly contextualized and that
certainly would include
the completely authoritarian debacle
that was
stalinist leninism why not students
should be taught that
but this is mandating propaganda this is
mandating perspective
plain and simple and when you hear that
part of this bill
uh a piece of the curriculum is patriots
uh portraits in patriotism
that should immediately set off alarm
bells and the very same
republicans who slam college and
university as liberal indoctrination
they are now mandating a form of actual
right-wing indoctrination to be taught
in high school and aside from being
completely absurd because
this is a blueprint for for long-term
brainwashing of children
this also strikes me as the type of
thing that uh desantis can later refer
to if he runs for president now don't
get me wrong
this is dangerous in and of itself you
start teaching kids at a young age
to associate communism with evil and
their portraits of patriotism which will
be of course mostly right wingers or
people who quote fled communism you you
start associating that with good
this is how you get them early this is a
quite literal brainwashing
but it also seems like exactly the type
of thing that desantis could later point
to as one of his great moral victories
if he decides to run for president and
say look at this thing i did in florida
and it's like the perfect virtue signal
to many of these right-wingers now for
everybody who's going to email me and
say david
you want them teaching that communism is
good don't you you want them teaching
that socialism is good that marxism is
good
i am not a socialist i am not a
communist i am not a marxist i'm a
social democrat
that's a form of well-regulated
capitalism what i do think however
because i value diversity of opinion and
teaching people to think for themselves
is that kids should be taught how
various economic systems work
how various forms of government work and
historical as well as current examples
of each
the pros and cons what achievements have
such systems had
what failures have they had how systems
can become corrupted uh and whether
certain systems are more prone to
corruption than others
this is called promoting critical
thinking it's the best safeguard we have
against
radicalization of all kinds it's much
more difficult to fear monger
successfully as a politician
when people are armed from a young age
with the ability to think for themselves
and figure out why do i believe
something that i believe
is do i have good reasons for believing
what i believe that's not what the ron
desantis bill
actually does it mandates the teaching
of a particular perspective
of propaganda it's a disaster and it is
the very thing that
they decry as they have identified it
so they say at the college level now
sometimes they've wrongly identified it
but now they're trying to do the exact
same thing in florida it's absolutely
disgusting
let me know your thoughts is this at all
surprising to you i'm not surprised that
this is what they're doing
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
that's p-a-k-m-a-n you do have to spell
it right
uh d-d-pacman on twitter let me know
your thoughts
one of our sponsors is blast light the
smallest
and most convenient uv disinfection
light on the market
covett is not over there are new
variants there might be future
resurgences so of course it's still
important to take precautions keep
yourself safe keep people around you
safe uvc lights have been proven to
safely and rapidly kill bacteria
mold fungi and viruses including covid19
blast light is a convenient keychain
uvc light that you can take wherever you
go
i keep it attached to my keys it goes
everywhere with me
it's easy to use it disinfects any
surface in just seconds
with a really long battery life and it's
rechargeable i've looked at a bunch of
different uvc light options
and this is by far the most compact and
portable one out there
blast light is normally 99 but my
audience can get it for 40
off which comes to 59.50 when you go to
davidpakman.com
blastlight the link is underneath this
video
not only can you become a supporting
member of the david pakman show at
joinpakman.com i also invite you to join
the discussion on our subreddit
uh i'm selling you nothing other than a
good time it's free you can find it at
davidpakman.com
reddit a couple of posts i spotted this
morning that i want to address
one user posted does anyone else feel
like the left needs to reclaim the
american flag
the right waves the flag and other
american symbols all day long
and most left-wing people don't even own
a flag i feel like it makes it easy for
them to paint us
as unpatriotic what are your thoughts
you know i tend to disagree with this to
me the flag waving
is very tacky and rather than reclaiming
the flag
i would rather see the left reclaim what
patriotism is
and make it something other than waving
a flag and when what i mean by that is
i've i've talked before
about a sort of more sensible logical
type of patriotism the philosopher alan
de bottom
has written about this as well which is
patriotism is
hey look at these amazingly well
designed cities we have
look at how much we've been able to
achieve in terms of
uh dealing with uh pollution and our
carbon footprint how
great should we feel about developing
alternative energy and
making sure people have health care
those are the things that should start
to be
reclaimed as patriotic rather than the
flag waving to me the flag waving is
just kind of tacky let's reclaim
patriotism uh rat you know in argentina
my birth country people who visit the us
from argentina often mention to me
what's with the flags like year i got
here i assumed it was flag day
because i just drive by houses and
people have flags on vehicles in some
states
what's going on with flags in argentina
and in many other countries
there's a day where you display the flag
and then it's sort of like we live
normal lives we're not constantly
fetishizing the flag
maybe going more in the direction where
the flag is less a symbol of
patriotism rather than trying to reclaim
the flag that's my
instinct but i'm i'm open to
having a different perspective presented
to me on the left and the flag
another post asks what the hell is
happening in august
something is clearly happening in august
there's a new york times story saying
trump is telling people he'll be
reinstated by august
i just heard mike lindell talk about
august does anyone here monitor maga
groups is there a plan yet what does
maga think is happening in august
i'd bet a thousand dollars right now
there's another coup attempt in the
works
does anyone have a concept of what that
might look like well tomorrow i'm
actually
going to talk about mike lindell is now
shifting from saying trump will be
reinstated in august to it could be
september
but i share the concern that there could
be violence
when of course trump doesn't get
reinstated whenever it is we've talked
about it
last week and and previously and um
i also have a fear that we may be
heading towards some kind of violence
when of course trump's not going to be
back in office this year
um and it remains to be seen if and when
that will take place but
that's what's going on that trump and
others have started floating august as
when trump will be back he obviously
won't
and there's no telling how that's going
to trigger some of his followers
join the discussion on the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit okay um for
months now the right has been saying
joe biden and kamala harris are
doing something really bad by not going
to the u.s mexico border they should go
there
now there's a separate discussion to be
had about
do you need to go to the border to
properly manage what's going on
with undocumented immigration there's a
separate discussion about
how is the biden administration managing
what's going on with undocumented
immigration
is there or is there not a crisis at the
border what has actually changed if
anything
since donald trump left office just over
five months ago
but the point here is that republicans
have been going
crazy saying why won't joe go
why won't kamala go here is a
republican-published compilation of why
won't they go to the border remember
this stuff
do you plans to visit the border
um you haven't been to the border so how
do you respond to that criticism and
when will that visit come when are you
going to the border
vice president the administration has
asked
i don't know i don't understand the
point that you're making
listen
[Music]
well kamala harris is now going to be
going
to the border um and of course now
republicans are completely satisfied and
they believe that
they are doing the right thing in the
biden administration just kidding
obviously they don't now they have
shifted to
why is kamala harris going to the wrong
part of the border
i i it i know it sounds completely
ridiculous but this is what they've now
shifted to
and also why is she going all of a
sudden well
you've been demanding it for months
right so here is republican texas
senator ted cruz also known to many as
cancun cruz
saying kamala harris is going to the
wrong
part of the border she's not going to
see the things that she needs to see
take a look at this but i gotta say even
this announcement so she announces that
they're going to el paso el paso is a
lovely city it is a beautiful place
in in texas it is not also it also
doesn't happen to be the locus of the
crisis
you look at where the rio grande valley
uh
is and and for folks who aren't from
texas let me give you a sense so el paso
is on
on the western tip of texas the rio
grande is
valley is almost on the southern tip of
texas it's 800 miles away to give you a
sense of just how far they are
chicago illinois is closer to washington
dc
than el paso is to mcallen and so she's
going where the where the height of the
problem isn't
let me tell you what kamala needs to do
kamala you need to go to the rio grande
valley kamala you need to go to mcallen
kamala you need to go to the donna tent
facility which is the tenth
city your administration has built
this is beyond parody this is how it
now she's doing the thing you've been
saying she should do
but now it's no longer the right thing
these people cannot
really be dealt with in a serious way
because of this
all along they said the issue was she's
not going to the border well now she is
and it's the wrong part
here is fox news reporter peter ducey
steve no peter yes peter ducey is the
the son
peter ducey asking white house press
secretary jen
saki why why why is this happening take
a look at this
so about today's announcement why is the
vice president visiting the border this
week
when earlier this month she dismissed a
trip like that saying it would be a
grand
gesture she also said um in an interview
with nbc that she would be open to going
to the border if it was an appropriate
time she said that after she said that
so that's important context as well
this is just a reminder okay this is
just a reminder
that we can't take them seriously
because they don't deserve to be taken
seriously as soon as you engage
with them in what you believe to be a
serious manner and say okay we're going
to go to the border let's figure out
what's going on there this is what you
wanted
now all of a sudden it's it's the wrong
place and why now and oh this that the
other thing
this is why i say don't even engage and
uh when when we say oh well why is joe
biden wasting time
inviting republicans to the white house
to talk about a bill he wants to pass
that makes sense to me you're actually
getting the people who
if they want to play a role in
legislation they can
you bring them to the oval office then
they say we're not going to vote for any
of this stuff
and then you go forward and you do it on
your own but you say listen i gave them
a shot that's one thing because that's
legislators
with this type of stuff go to the border
okay we're going well now it's the wrong
place and why now and the timing is
suspect
i don't think it makes any sense to
engage with it whatsoever if you think
it does make sense let me know
i see no upside what whatsoever these
people are pathetic they will never be
satisfied this is the game
it's grievance culture and outrage the
right
has made it a a regular talking point to
say that the left has become about
grievances
i'm seeing that on the right my friends
and this is a perfect example of it
i want to talk a little bit about a
critical race theory protest
gone completely haywire in ashburn
virginia the school board of this
wealthy county loudoun county in
virginia
wanted to hold a meeting to close out
the school year
and it became complete and total chaos
in this washington dc suburb as parents
who apparently are against critical race
theory although it's not
completely clear they really know what
it is they wanted to protest critical
race theory
we're going to look at some video clips
here this is wild wild stuff here is
one parent um the founder of parents
against critical race theory speaking to
a crowd
outside the event take a listen to this
all they keep doing is changing the
narrative
clinical race theory is culturally
responsive framework
culturally responsive teaching it's all
just trojan horses inequity
diversity and inclusion you know come on
you know one thing yeah who would want
any of that stuff guys i mean that's
just crazy it's crazy what they're
trying to teach
now i i am a critic of critical race
theory
um this you know we one of the things
that happens in academia is
you have a theory and then you have
critiques of the theory
and that's all normal and good uh but
we don't we don't want to teach
inclusion we don't want to teach the
value of equality i mean
it's he doesn't even really seem to
understand what critical race theory is
then of course they broke into the
national anthem
listen to this
i think you get the the impression this
is not it's it's they're just standing
in the parking lot singing the national
anthem
again if you were to satire
um sort of like ignorant clueless uh
protests of critical race theory this is
what they would look like
um then the crowd inside the event
wouldn't shut up and they had to
threaten to end the meeting
[Applause]
[Music]
so there were threats that if these
people don't quiet down they're gonna
have to
uh end the meeting uh and then they did
actually end the public comment section
and people went completely nuts
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
so that was after the announcement that
they were going to have to wrap the
thing up because people were going
completely crazy
um and things just continued getting
wilder and wilder take a look
oh this is when they go back into the
national anthem the meeting was ended
and they go back into the national
anthem
[Music]
dear god
[Music]
so that went on and then um then the
arrest started happening
uh here is you will this is while an
arrest is going on you i think in this
clip you hear someone yell who pays your
salary to the police officers as well
[Music]
okay so people getting completely
outraged i guess they're mad at
everything getting mad at the police
getting mad at the school board getting
mad at the t
everybody's furious with everybody and
then this is sort of like the cherry on
top here is a guy
uh getting getting himself arrested in
the midst of this
[Music]
by the way you know we talk about
resisting arrest is used as a catch-all
when police
want to manhandle someone um
by the standards we normally see applied
to what counts as resisting arrest this
guy's doing it and
police treating him very very politely
as you can tell
[Music]
the officer says the meeting is over and
the guy says it's not you can see if
you're watching the video that there's
almost no one left
so the meeting clearly is over i think
that's more of an empirical question the
meeting has ended but just another
complete and total humiliation and
this is sort of a mind virus this is an
example of where
the idea of critical race theory
as an indoctrination strategy in high
schools
has spread like a virus among some of
these
right wingers and they can no longer
think
sensibly they can no longer behave like
adults it's a real sad thing to see
but they seem to have really latched on
to this in a pretty serious way
i don't expect this to go away anytime
soon and we may do
even a deep dive on critical race theory
at some point in the next few weeks
because it is becoming i mean listen
these are adults supposedly and look at
what
the idea the misunderstood idea that
they have of critical race theory has
done to them
i'm all for serious critiques of
critical race theory
i've done them i think it's reductive
and i i think it's not
uh the type of theory that will further
race relations
but i'm not going to be showing up uh
and getting myself arrested and
screaming i i'm just glad to talk to
people about it in a calm sensible and
rational way
i don't expect this to end any time soon
we'll have some more of these clips on
the show's instagram
which you can find at davidpakmanshow
you can also find me on instagram at
david.pakman we'll take a quick break
and be right back
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's
exactly what one of my favorite apps
lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr alok kenosha who's a
psychiatrist
practicing in boston massachusetts and
on the faculty at harvard medical school
also the co-founder of healthy gamer an
organization
using meditation and advances in
neuroscience and coaching
to help gamers take back control of
their lives
it's great to have you back on today
thanks a lot david it's a pleasure to be
here again
so what are you seeing generally maybe
to get us into the conversation
about what's going on with people's
mental health and
psyche and sort of predisposition to
what is now starting to hopefully be an
exit
from from the pandemic yeah so it's a
great question so during the pandemic we
saw
um an increase in depressive symptoms uh
so
there was a paper by the journal of the
american medical association which
basically found a 300 percent
worsening in depression during the
pandemic
and so as people were sort of getting
enclosed um also like
lower access to vitamin d and things
like that resulted in worsening
depression
the really fascinating thing is i'm
seeing something that i really haven't
heard
clinically described which i would call
reintegration anxiety
which is very unusual but basically
people have been enclosed
so long and i see this a lot in the
university students that we work with
that they're like actually concerned
about like they want to re-engage
with the real world but they feel
anxious that socially they become rusty
they're not sure that they're going to
be able to do in-person school
so it's really interesting because
there's almost some degree of like fear
about reintegrating
into the real world some of this i
see in in a very um what seems more
like just unknowns about the data
right which is okay when i go to the
grocery store
and i see people without a mask now i'm
imagining
that there is just virus coming out of
their mouth right it's because this is
this is what
we the idea that was sort of ingrained
in us before vaccination and
and so on and so forth but you're saying
this goes beyond just
waiting to understand and feel good
about the science it's something above
and beyond this
yeah absolutely so if we look at like
our brains
when we don't use a particular circuit
in our brain
it rusts so if i speak two languages and
i don't speak one of the languages for a
year i get rusty
so what we find in covid is everyone is
interacting online
so there are parts of our brain which
make us feel socially reassured
like the parts of our brain which will
interpret body language
tone facial expressions and things like
that which on online interactions we
don't really get
so now as people are starting to
reintegrate into society and like
socially be active in person those
rusty circuits of our brain are causing
us to like not
feel reassured and i'm seeing this
bizarre spike in social anxiety
as people are reintegrating yeah and
it's really strange
there are people um there are people i
know which is related i think to social
anxiety who have said you know i went to
the grocery store
and they're back to full capacity i was
wearing a mask but some people weren't
and i just
almost had like a panic response like i
i'm just going to
take my two items i've grabbed and not
finished my shop and i'm leaving
is that a sort of a agoraphobia type
response that's taking place
i i wouldn't quite call it agoraphobia
because if we think about agoraphobia
it's the
it's usually like the inability to
control circumstances which causes you
to retreat into your home
um what i really think it is is almost
what you were saying we've been sort of
conditioned
to fear people without masks
right we've been told there have been
death tolls and stories about
you know refrigeration trucks filled
with bodies with covid
there's a lot of information about these
new variants which are ripping through
countries that previously were doing
pretty well so i think the people
especially who have taken that to heart
and have been careful are going to be
the ones that will you know we've we've
conditioned ourselves to be afraid of
that thing
so it's almost like a conditioned
response like a conditioned fear
that now we have to start undoing i've
um
told my audience that all along i've
followed cdc guidelines even when i
didn't really think i needed to be
wearing a mask on the bike path
outdoors i did it because people around
me were and it was sort of like a social
calculation
that that i made and now as
masks are coming off i've said you know
i was just traveling
and where i went people weren't wearing
masks in grocery stores so i didn't
either but then
when i got back i stick my head into the
grocery store i mostly see masks
i put my mask on i have no medical
reason why i'm doing
that right the cdc guidelines are i
don't need that mask
is it in some way bad that i'm doing
this
merely to just not stand out as the guy
not wearing a mask
is there some some concerning longer
term
impact of me behaving in that way well
let's start by understanding why you
behave that way which is because your
brain is wired to behave that way
okay right so if we think about you know
how do children learn language
how do children learn body like you know
body movements and if we think about
as our language evolves over time you
know we start to use new slang
it's because our brain is literally
wired we're communal
animals as homo sapiens and we look at
what the
other homo sapiens are doing and we are
gonna feel like doing the same thing
it's why peer pressure is a thing it's
why fashion fads are a thing
it's just the way that we're wired now
what impact that's gonna have on you i
mean i don't really know i think it's
just part of the way we all
are and and you're going to kind of be
like monkey see monkey do yeah which to
a sense is fine
i think the real challenge comes when
there are for example cdc guidelines and
large populations of people
who don't want to follow them right so
this is where they're kind of like
monkey see monkey do brain is telling
them oh don't bother wearing a mask
when it really is important because
there are new strains there are
other kinds of considerations to really
think about um
and so i i don't really i'm not
concerned about the psychological impact
of like switching
whether you wear masks or not right
because everyone's going to
re-equilibrate
to like what's a you know what's a
healthy amount of mask wearing
speaking of equilibrium you mentioned
the significant increase
in in depression and reported depressive
symptoms during the pandemic i know many
people who have gone on
uh serotonin antidepressants the the
ones that have been around for for
decades at this point in time
what is the medical science at this
point about
the um from what i looked at before our
conversation it seems like a typical
course of those is often
like a 12 to 18 month period and then
often people start kind of coming off of
those
would it be expected that when people
get beyond this
phase of the pandemic where maybe they
don't feel that they need those
medications anymore
that they're going to go sort of back to
their pre-pandemic depressive state or
does this stuff tend to be sort of
sticky and persistent
uh so it's not going to be sticky and
persistent based on my professional
experience
okay i i'm just going to say that i
don't think that
if you have a pandemic-induced
depression i don't know that a ssri
is actually like an appropriate clinical
response
interesting so so let's remember that
depression is a symptom
actually and has multiple diagnoses that
can lead to depression
so you can have cancer-induced
depression you can have bipolar disorder
you can have major depressive disorder
you can have depressive symptoms
relating to trauma and what really ssris
have been studied
very well in is these neurochemical
imbalances really within major
depressive disorder
so i would first of all you know
personally i've been hesitant to just
prescribe ssris to people who are coming
in for the first time
depressed during the pandemic because we
know that depressive symptoms can be
highly circumstantial
and really changing those circumstances
is is really the permanent solution
that being said so if we kind of assume
that for a second i wouldn't expect that
the gigantic crop of people who got put
on ssris
will need them going forward so i do
think it's reasonable to pull off of
medication within
i mean generally speaking i'll try
within six months to a year
um interesting i think 18 months is even
sounds a little bit long to me because
the data suggests that a depressive
episode resolves on its own within one
year basically
uh i want to talk a little bit about
something that that's
maybe a little more in the political
space and whether you do or don't want
to
get involved in the political commentary
part is fine but
we've been seeing uh what seems to me as
a kind of
coping mechanism for those who supported
the former president
in in the election um essentially
denying that he really lost and if we
think of
denial as maybe the first stage in a
process
sometimes in life um there seems to be
sort of like an inability to move on
from the denial phase that i'm noticing
and
he's going to be back in august or maybe
it's september and this type of thing
is that what what do you make of that do
people sometimes never move on from the
denial phase
um i i really can't make much of that to
be honest because what i really like to
do david is like talk to these people
right so
and see what's going on specifically
yeah so i mean i i definitely think that
people
can get attached to a particular idea
and they have trouble letting go of that
idea but i think if we really want to
understand
you know why the denial is so sticky to
use one of your words yeah i think the
real question is what does it
mean to these people that you know trump
did lose
and what does it mean to these people if
he comes back because usually what i
find in in persistent denial
yeah is that it's not the actual thing
it's what that thing
means to the person so the world will be
a better place and i want the world to
be a better place if
x y or z happens right and so i think
it's the association or the meaning or
the interpretation
of the particular event which makes the
denial so sticky so the
maybe asking one of these folks like
when they call in to me
what would it mean to you to accept that
trump
genuinely just did lose and that might
give me insight
into why they're not moving on from the
denial
yeah i would modify that question a
little bit i wouldn't say to accept
what did it mean what does it mean to
you if trump lost
right you know what does it mean to you
if he never comes back
what would that say about the world what
would that say because i i think what it
is is it's really the
what it says about the world is what
they don't want to accept
they don't want to live in a world where
this kind of thing happens
right so they're going to continue
hoping that this is not the world that
they live in that would be my best guess
in your practice do you see people who
who maybe have a depressive or an
anxiety
sort of uh a situation that is caused by
the sort of general events that are
taking place in society not the pandemic
is like a very specific medical event
but sort of like
what they identify as a political
problem or something along those lines
absolutely dude so like this is why like
we started healthy gamer because i think
what's happening is depression
used to be an isolated neurochemical
imbalance malfunction in the brain
right but there's almost like a societal
generational
or existential depression that we see
all throughout like gen z
in millennials to be honest and and so
like you know the world is just becoming
a bleak place
and how do people deal with that you
know when
when when how can i wake up as a
sophomore
in college when i know that every year
that goes by i'm racking up
an insurmountable amount of debt that as
i enter the job market i'm like getting
into a trench that i'm never going to
escape from
right how can i get the motivation to
study and if you go in to see a
psychiatrist they will check
certain boxes diagnose you with
depression and put you on a pill
and i just don't know that i mean can it
help absolutely could there be an
underlying
neurochemical malfunction absolutely but
i think part of the reason that healthy
gamer has grown so much
um and we basically just got started
right after i was on your show
the last time yeah is because there you
know we need different kinds of
solutions
um in terms of dealing with these
different and new
like causes of depression like this
existential depression is absolutely
real
i mean the the student loan thing it's
almost like a capitalism-based
depression of sorts
yeah i mean so i think that this is
where like something something about the
way that our personal psychology
is being affected by world events seems
to be
a lot tighter so a hundred years ago i
don't know that world events
affected people's psychology so much
yeah but as world events
get pushed on our mind so much they
start to have a bigger
personal effect on us and that's
actually part of the reason that we
started as an organization because i
don't think the old systems of
psychiatry
are sufficient to deal with those kinds
of things
no question about that that part seems
uh that part seems abundantly clear
a healthy gamer is the organization
we've been speaking with its co-founder
dr
olok konoja who's a psychiatrist
practicing in boston massachusetts and
also on the faculty at harvard medical
school
always great speaking to you i
appreciate it thanks a lot david it was
a pleasure to be back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive of every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount
join pacman.com all right this is a
super interesting story and a very
different um
uh sort of military related story than
what many of us have become accustomed
to
yesterday the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff general mark milley
was asked questions by republican
congressman
matt gates about the u.s military
examining critical race theory now the
the term examining
is really the appropriate term
understanding
marxian economics doesn't make you a
marxist
and much the same way examining critical
race theory
doesn't make you someone who
guides their philosophy or runs a
military on the basis of critical race
theory although
you may learn something that's relevant
or furthers your understanding or maybe
not but the point is
simply understanding something examining
it
learning about it doesn't actually
dictate your political
philosophy and uh matt gates
and others were just uh getting after
general mark milley and he delivered
a concise and very astute
explanation of why i mean forget about
just critical race theory there's a
bigger issue here
which is the right he doesn't say the
right but
i've been pointing out the right seems
to fail to understand
the value of diverse knowledge
for its own sake rather than
necessarily as a tool of indoctrination
so let's take a look at this clip this
is general mark milly
super super interesting stuff you'll see
the camera if you're watching go to matt
gates at one point who's just sort of
shaking his head and he
doesn't like it but he seems to know
he's being schooled right now take a
look mr chair and thank you gentlemen
for joining us today
i know my time is very precious but i
would like to yield some of my time to
general milley because i know
that he had some comments that he wanted
to make when representative
gates was talking as well as mr waltz
about a similar subject of the stand
down
and race theory would you like a minute
or so to comment on that do you remember
what we were
what your line of questioning or thought
was there um
sure um first of all on the
issue of critical race theory etc i'll
obviously have to get much smarter on
whatever the theory is um but i do think
it's important
actually for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read and
the united states military academy is a
university
and it is important that we train and we
understand
uh and i i want to understand white rage
understand what he's pointing out here
right the military trains for many
contingencies which never happen
the military trains to understand
circumstances uh which may be good
bad neutral or irrelevant because that's
what you do you prepare
you learn you understand similarly when
you apply that and say hey this is a
university
you learn things in university from
math i mean listen have i used calculus
2
in my work life no but understanding it
and going through it has been
extraordinarily valuable
in terms of now i understand how do we
even learn
math at that level which is not a
particularly high level but i'm not i'm
not bragging but i'm just saying
i'm not using it but it's still useful
and much the same way we should be
seeing
some of this these ideologies and and
theories as well
right now that's an academic it's it's
the most basic
thing right about what we do what
learning is i want to understand it
so what is it that caused thousands of
people to assault
this building and try to overturn the
constitution of the united states of
america what caused that
right i want to find that out i want to
maintain an open mind here and i do want
to analyze it
it's important that we understand that
because our soldiers sailors airmen
marines and guardians
they come from the american people so it
is important by the way guardians that's
the space force trump thing i he you
know he has to say it it just it sounds
so weird to hear it that the leaders now
and in the future do understand it i've
read miles seyton
i've read i've read karl marx i've read
lenin that doesn't make me a communist
this thi i mean this is the this is
literally the example i gave earlier in
the show
when i was at the university of
massachusetts amherst one of the few
then uh economics programs which
seriously taught what the class was
marxian economics with the
with the late uh steven resnick a
co-author
with richard wolff uh in many articles
and and even books i believe um
it didn't turn me into a marxist but i i
learned what is the theory what is the
genesis we we read mark there was
nothing dangerous going on
it's called being informed uh and to
hear mark milley say it i have to tell
you
is fantastic so what is wrong
with understanding having some
situational understanding about the
country for which we are here to defend
and i personally find it offensive that
we are accusing
the united states military our general
officers our commission non-commissioned
officers
of being quote woke or something else
because we're studying some theories
that are out there that was started at
harvard law school years ago and it
proposed
that there were laws in the united
states anti-bellum laws prior to the
civil war
that led to a power differential with
african-americans that were
three-quarters of a human
by the way the general knows much more
about all of these topics than matt
gates but that probably doesn't come as
a surprise to anybody
being when this country was formed and
then we had a civil war and emancipation
proclamation
to change it and we brought it up to the
civil rights act in 1964 it took another
hundred years to change that
so look it i do want to know and i
respect your service and you and i are
both green berets
but i want to know and it matters by the
way it's not
matt gates that's the green beret it's a
different congressman who's there
military in the discipline and cohesion
of this military
and i thank you for the opportunity to
make a comment on that thank you general
so the general is completely right this
is just called thinking this is called
being a student of things
this is called learning uh understanding
and um it it makes absolute
perfect sense that uh this would be the
perspective that an
entity like the military would take and
um it doesn't mean the military becomes
woke in the negative sense of the
of the term now just just to give you
one reaction to this which is so funny
after this last night laura ingraham on
fox news
responded to this and she said the
reason this happened
is because of democrats and the
military-industrial complex
this she's like a trapeze artist she's a
she's a contortionist
i don't know how this is what she comes
up with but let's listen the active duty
service men and women about that sir
now somehow i don't think general milley
would ever speak
in this dismissive tone that he took
today
to his chinese counterparts not the way
he spoke to congressman waltz who
questioned him
what i have a question for the general
why would anyone risk his or her life
for a country
that's systemically racist one that
brutalizes minorities
this is what you call uh black and white
thinking
let's assume for a second that it wasn't
just that mark millie said
let's understand critical race theory
imagine for a second that what mark
milley said
was the military will now see
critical race theory as its guiding
explanation
and system for understanding the country
that's not what he said but imagine that
mark milley went as far as to say that
now laura ingram says why would anyone
be in the military to defend a country
that's structurally racist well
you underst for those who subscribe to
critical race theory
presumably the next step is how do we
fix it
and the same or similar motivation that
would lead someone
if they join the military for the right
reasons which is
well for i mean we can argue about
whether the military is used in this way
but
if you join not to go and kill people as
some some do but most don't
if you join the military to try to make
the country better
and if you believe critical race theory
you would then want to
change things to make the country better
in both cases you're trying to make the
country better so hurt this black and
white thinking of
if there's any systemic racism then you
wouldn't even be in the military because
you'd not want to defend a country
that's systemically racist
it's just gutter black and white
thinking why would any country respect
us or follow our lead if that's who we
are
those are some of the questions he
should probably think about
before he touts the value of teaching
far left marxist racist ideology to our
troops
and again all he touted was we want to
understand what are the conversations
that are happening
and what are the arguments being made he
never said
let's become a woke critical race theory
military that
had he said that it would be a different
discussion the fact is millie
has made his choice and he's chosen to
indulge the radical whims of democrats
he'll do everything they tell him as
long as they keep the
military-industrial complex flush with
cash
and of course that's just so silly given
that
you know military industrial complex
is almost as big of an issue in terms of
blind support from democrats than from
republicans
a little bit less you do hear some
democrats say
we've got to pare this down so for laura
ingraham now to say well that
this is all happening he's taking a left
perspective
because of democrats funneling money
into the military-industrial complex
republicans do far more of it so it's
it makes no sense one way or the other
and very
interesting to see the statements by
general mark milley
hey this is a really interesting story
um there is a new report
cnn and others reporting that ivanka
trump and jared kushner
are now distanced and maybe even
estranged from former president donald
trump
because of his complete inability to
move on from having lost the 2020
election
cnn reports with each passing day away
from washington former
president trump's grievances continue
unabated and those complaints appear to
be driving away two of the people who
were closest to him
during his white house tenure his
daughter ivanka trump
and his son-in-law jared kushner
going on to say a large part of the
reason for the separation
is trump's constant harping on the past
and his inability to move on the former
president has also started to question
the role that kushner one of the few
people
who were able to stay close to trump
throughout his two presidential
campaigns in white house tenure
has played in his presidential legacy
ivanka trump has also struggled to undo
the entanglements caused by the years at
her father's side in the white house
as she seeks a less complicated life for
her family
according to two acquaintances that
seems like a reference to the complete
disaster that was ivanka and jared
trying to reintegrate themselves into
new york city life and being
shunned they described her as having to
walk a fine line between embracing her
father
and distancing herself from the election
lies
one club-goer at mar-a-lago and family
friends said they weren't around
for the usual spring and summer events
at mar-a-lago
noting the absence of trump's elder
daughter and the couple's three young
children
simultaneously the disappearance of
kushner once the ringleader of trump's
policy
was also apparent a person familiar with
kushner
says there were visits from the kushner
trump family to mar-a-lago
long before before trump's moved north
but they were sparse
averaging one every three to four weeks
the physical distance between them was
not
far because kushner and ivanka were
living in miami
awaiting the construction of their
mansion on a nearby uh
private island kushner's presence
physically and virtually has become
increasingly rare
as it became clear that his
father-in-law remained preoccupied with
the 2020 election
according to one person familiar with
the situation
um this is not hugely surprising to me
you know uh it became clear in the late
days of the trump administration that
in particular jared and ivanka and
especially ivanka
were realizing that the reintegration
was not going to go
super smoothly there were reports about
their they're being shunned by the high
society circles in which they previously
ran
and this is not i don't i don't feel bad
for them i don't care they chose this
um you know tiffany trump for example
stayed out of the limelight and i'm
aware of her having many
left-wing friends and she sort of goes
in in different circles and is not being
shunned in the same way although her
role at the republican national
convention was pretty disgusting
don jr and eric are fully bought in
to continuing the sycophantic brown
nosing you see them regularly on fox
news
and newsmax and on other programs so
they've they've
kind of staked out that position in the
aftermath of the trump administration
ivanka and jared and in particular
ivanka have removed themselves from
politics
but they were so visible and so involved
during this administration
that now people are saying we we don't
we don't like you you know before we
accepted you
and you were less overtly political and
at least you weren't actively going
around as republicans remember trump was
a democrat much of his life so whether
we liked you or not they were kind of
tolerated in these high society circles
in manhattan and
and los angeles miami et cetera but
they're they're they're now in a sense
uh tainted but and kushner just
disastrous participation remember
they're out it's our stockpile it's not
their stockpile that entire thing
um he's doing masks he's doing schwabs
and all of this stuff
it's become so humiliating and so
embarrassing that now
they're having trouble reintegrating
into society that's their choice
but the estrangement from donald trump
is very interesting and the political
connection is
is a very narrow one which
we'll mention briefly uh
one question about trump 2024 is what
will trump's health be like then
second question about trump 2024 is will
he still have the bulk of the republican
party behind him
third question about 2024 is will
trump's
favorites win in 22 and if they don't
does that hurt his chances
but there's another question here which
is if there is a trump 2024 run
does he have the same coalition of his
family strongly supporting him because
for not not all but for many of these
right wingers particularly the
evangelicals
they had to be like well they al most
they all were lied to but the
evangelical specifically had to be lied
to about oh trump's pro-life now
he's been pro-choice his whole life
suddenly six months before running for
president he's
he's pro-life the evangelicals had to be
sold that bill of goods
and similarly trump has a family man
with his children all around him
even though the cheating the divorce you
know all this different stuff it doesn't
matter they were able to ignore it
but the the family unit around trump was
a big piece
uh for some of those evangelicals along
with the lies about abortion and other
things
in them ultimately coming around to him
without that does trump have the same
cachet for some of these religious
rightists if the family
is not around him i don't know the
answer to that question but it's
something we will know
uh before too long we have a voicemail
number and that number is 2192 david p
here is a left-wing gun owner and she
calls in and she says perfectly
nobody's coming for my guns democrats
aren't coming for my guns why are people
worried about this and she's completely
right take a look at this
hi david this is joe from virginia
please
maybe you could explain to me why
the right things that the democrats are
coming
for their guns i mean i'm
i'm a leftist i well i'm actually an
independent leaning left
uh progressive uh but i have a gun
but i don't feel threatened that
the government is coming for my gun so
maybe you could explain to some of us
why the right is so irrational
about that they're coming for their guns
i just
don't understand what the problem is
it's
two things listen you're absolutely
right democrats aren't coming for your
guns legal we have a second amendment
legal gun owners are going to be able to
continue owning
if anything even changes legal gun
owners will be able to continue having
their guns there might be some
restrictions around the edges on certain
types of high-powered firearms or you
know
limited things there's two things that
are going on one
this stuff plays really well in
activating right-wing gun owners to say
that democrats are coming for your guns
gets people
to go out and vote against democrats
number two
the gun lobby including the nra and some
other smaller groups like gun owners of
america if it's still around and others
they sell lots of guns for their clients
which are the gun companies the
manufacturers
by saying either democrats are about to
come and take your guns
or look at all these shootings it's
really unsafe you've got to go and get
guns to protect yourself no matter
what's going on
if shootings are down they would say
they're down because people have guns go
get guns
if shootings are up they'd say it's
dangerous out there go get guns to
protect yourself
if a democrat's in office they say
they're coming for your guns you've got
to go out and get more guns so all of
that together
leads to exactly what joe is describing
very well said
we have a great bonus show for you today
the supreme court is restricting police
powers
to enter homes without a warrant when
the
a crime one is suspected of as a minor
crime we'll talk more about that
we will talk about the identification of
29
planets from which intelligent life
could observe earth and we will also
talk about canadian lawmakers at the
federal level
passing a bill which criminalizes lgbt
conversion therapy
so-called so-called all of those stories
and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com
to get instant access
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blastlight is the world's smallest and
most convenient
uvc disinfection light to help keep you
safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com blastlight to get
it for 40 percent off
the link is down below blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman